mon invité a longtemps préféré l'ombre à
la lumière mais cela ne l'a pas empêché
pour autant de devenir porte-parole du
groupe rassemblement national à
l'Assemblée
[Musique]
bonjour Thomas ménager alors pendant le
débat sur la réforme des retraites une
de vos prises de parole a déclencher
beaucoup de réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux mais pas seulement on va le voir
c'était sur la question du report de
l'âge légal à 64 ans
laissez-nous expliquer au gouvernement
la vraie vie je vais vous prendre
l'exemple de mon père mon père a 58 ans
mon père a travaillé toute sa vie sur
les toits et les couvreurs mon père a 58
ans aujourd'hui chaque soir allait
genoux qui double de volume chaque matin
est incapable de se lever parce qu'il
est cassé vous êtes pour la plupart
détaché des réalités détachées des
difficultés de ce monde venez sur le
terrain et vous comprendrez que pour une
partie des Français il est impossible
d'aller jusqu'à 64 ans alors cette prise
de parole elle a déclenché une riposte
assez cinglante de la majorité par la
voix de Stéphanie Rist personne n'a le
monopole du papa qui a souffert vous
êtes elle répondu vous comprenez que ça
puisse un peu agacer cette façon de
faire de la politique de jouer sur les
émotions pour défendre ses idées je
considère que quand on s'engage en
politique on est le fruit de notre
histoire de notre passé de notre famille
et donc automatiquement parfois quand ça
touche directement à notre quotidien à
nos familles on s'exprime et donc on
prend les exemples que l'on connaît que
l'on connaît rien et donc Stéphanie iris
c'est vrai avait réagi je voulais pas
m'octroyer un quelconque monopole je
voulais juste faire expliquer au
gouvernement qu'il y avait des Français
qui ne seraient pas en capacité et je le
savais parce que j'avais mon père
régulièrement au téléphone et qui me
disait mais moi je pourrai pas je ne
pourrai pas aller plus plus longtemps
sur les toits était comme hiver et que
c'était quelque chose de très difficile
donc c'est pas du tout un monopole et
c'est vrai que Stéphanie risque elle
avait peut-être plus de pudeur on en a
parlé après parce que je pouvais
comprendre que ça l'avait aussi elle a
raconté l'histoire de son père également
qui tenait un café donc après on a parlé
on a parlé de nos histoires personnelles
mais c'est ça ce que je reprochais à une
partie des députés de la majorité sur
cette réforme des retraites c'est quand
bien même ils étaient pour certains dans
la réalité des choses ils avaient des
familles qui avaient pu être confrontés
à la difficulté à la pénibilité ils
avaient tendance à l'oublier et donc
c'est ce que j'ai souhaité leur rappeler
et c'est vrai que j'ai réalisé par les
réactions notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux que les gens se sentaient aussi
représentés entendus et concernés et
concerné directement parce que j'ai eu
incroyablement
énormément de retour même de personnes
du bâtiment pour cette vidéo sur votre
compte Tik Tok quand même 3000 vues
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les Français on
le sentiment que on ne sait pas ce qu'il
a été qu'on est un petit peu en orbite
qu'on est hors sol ils ont le sentiment
avec le président de la République ils
ont le sentiment aussi avec une partie
de députés et donc quand ils ont
l'impression qu'on est des réelles
portes paroles de leur préoccupation et
de la réalité du terrain et ils nous
remercient alors je disais à l'instant
que ça a pu agacer et en même temps on
sent que quand vous vous exprimez
là-dessus vous remuez des choses très
personnelles sur votre histoire à vous
est-ce que vous faites un lien entre le
milieu social dans lequel vous avez
grandi et votre engagement en politique
totalement enfin moi j'ai un mauvais
parents n'ont pas le bac c'est surtout
été aussi un une réelle volonté de
participer à changer les choses
notamment au niveau de l'ascenseur
social moi je viens d'une petite commune
de 800 habitants ruralité mais pas en
n'ont pas le bac ils se sont entre
guillemets saignés pour faire en sorte
que je puisse aller à l'université et
donc bah déjà j'ai envie de les rendre
fiers et j'essaie de jamais oublier d'où
je viens même si par la suite j'ai fait
des études que j'ai eu un confort
personnel financier et un mode de vie
différent de ma famille à chaque fois et
surtout quand en tant que Néo député je
suis arrivé dans l'Assemblée nationale
bah j'ai eu une pensée pour mes ancêtres
et pour mes parents bien entendu vous
êtes engagé en politique très jeune à 15
ans vous avez soutenu la campagne de
Nicolas Sarkozy vous avez ensuite pris
votre carte à l'UMP mais quand on vous
demande ce qui a été l'élément
déclencheur de votre engagement vous
évoquez un drame personnel la mort de
votre maman à 19 ans ça a été ça a été
un moment important alors dans un
premier temps je pense que c'était un
peu une fuite en avant c'est-à-dire que
la politique comme c'est quelque chose
on se donne totalement c'était
l'occasion de ne pas de sentir utile de
trouver un sens quand on a l'impression
quand on est jeune comme moi que la
paire d'une maman fait perdre un peu du
sens à la vie de sentir utile d'essayer
de penser à autre chose et bien entendu
ça accéléré l'engagement la volonté de
se mettre au service des autres et et
dans un premier temps j'aimerais que je
le cache pas un peu d'oublier ce moment
qui a été très difficile pour moi en
2012 vous je vais commencer à avoir une
première visibilité médiatique c'était
en tant que porte-parole de la manif
pour tous localement à Blois pourquoi
vous êtes vous mobilisé contre le
mariage gay est-ce que c'était lié par
exemple à des convictions religieuses ou
pas du tout c'était absolument pas
religieux c'était là encore quelques
mois c'était réellement je pense qu'il y
a accéléré cet engagement après le décès
de ma mère et moi j'ai ressenti sur la
question de l'adoption et on peut
ressortir tous les articles de l'époque
le mariage était pas un problème pour
moi c'était la filiation je venais de
perdre la présence féminine à mes côtés
et je m'interrogeais sur la nécessité
dans la construction de l'enfant d'avoir
une présence féminine et masculine je
demandais aussi un référendum il y avait
aussi un engagement contre François
Hollande à l'époque et aujourd'hui 10
ans après moi je regrette pas parce que
je l'ai fait dans le respect de chacun
je suis très heureux aussi de voir que
les doutes que je pouvais avoir sur la
question de l'affiliation aujourd'hui
sont levées que je me suis peut-être
entre guillemets trompé par rapport à
mes doutes et surtout on demandait
comment on le demande aujourd'hui et
c'est aussi ça qui a participé à mon
engagement national que sur les sujets
de société
que ça soit la société régler les soucis
par le référendum et de la même manière
quand il y a des sujets bloquants comme
c'était le cas je pense sur les
retraites ça aurait dû être le cas pour
pour ce que ça veut dire que si on
refait ce débat parlementaire
aujourd'hui si la loi repasser
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle vous
voteriez à nouveau contre non non je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vous avez évolué
j'ai évolué ouais j'avais 19 ans j'avais
pas du tout les le même le même vision
et puis le monde a évolué on s'est rendu
compte qu'on pouvait avoir des
inquiétudes sur la question et qu'au
final les inquiétudes qu'on pouvait
avoir ben elles étaient pas fondées je
considère qu'en politique il faut
surtout être en cohérence on a le droit
de poser des questions on a le droit de
s'interroger et aujourd'hui moi je suis
content que tout le monde puisse s'aimer
librement en France je m'inquiète quand
même pour les homosexuels aujourd'hui
sur quand même d'autres combats
notamment le combat contre le
fondamentaliste islamiste qui menace un
certain nombre de droits et et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que la question il
faut pas rouvrir même si là on est dans
les 10 ans cette question qui est
aujourd'hui régler c'est tant mieux une
question aussi les rares images que j'ai
retrouvé de vous à l'époque en fouillant
à droite à gauche là c'est seul qui a il
y a plus rien de vous sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment sur vos comptes vous
avez tout effacé alors moi j'ai quand
j'ai vraiment pris un engagement auprès
de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan j'ai remis en
cause l'ensemble de mes réseaux sociaux
parce que je considère que la parole
d'un gamin de 16 17 18 ans les photos de
famille les photos avec ses proches des
prises de position quand on est gamin
les photos de famille ça je peux
comprendre mais là c'était un engagement
public comme si vous n'assumiez plus moi
j'ai j'ai entre guillemets j'ai
recommencé des comptes à zéro juste
après parce que je considérais que je
voulais pas être responsable des propos
que je pouvais avoir à 15-16 ans sur les
réseaux sociaux mes photos en soirée
avec mes amis il y avait rien de
répréhensible ou le gênant et ce qui
avait dans la presse était très clair
mais je considérais qu'il fallait quand
on quand on devient un personnage
politique public il faut bien entendu
être responsable de ses propos et
aujourd'hui depuis mon engagement aux
côtés Nicolas Dupont-Aignan tout est
public bien sûr en mai 2014 vous avez
posté une photo de votre carte de
militants en UMP on vous interrogeant
sur le fait de rester sinon au sein de
ce parti et quelques mois plus tard vous
l'avez quitté pour rejoindre Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan pourquoi j'avais des
doutes depuis un petit moment comme
beaucoup de militants l'UMP même si
j'étais pas pleinement engagé voilà
j'avais ma carte sur la ligne du parti
sur la réelle défense des classements
moyennes la valeur du travail sur depuis
Nicolas Sarkozy j'avais des doutes sur
la capacité à passer le karcher qu'on
nous avait promis sur la question du
régalien sur la question de la
souveraineté à l'époque pour être très
clair moi j'étais pas prêt à rejoindre
le front national c'était encore le
passé de Jean-Marie Le Pen et celui qui
portait la ligne du RPR ancien et une
ligne compatible avec avec Marine Le Pen
c'était Nicolas Dupont-Aignan et donc
dès 2015 vous êtes devenu son chef de
cabinet vous êtes restés dans son ombre
tout du long de cet engagement à ses
côtés mais au cœur de son dispositif au
point que vous avez participé
directement au négociations avec Marine
Le Pen après le second tour de la
présidentielle et avant les législatives
en 2017 ça a été une étape clé de votre
engagement qu'est-ce qui s'est joué pour
vous à ce moment là c'était un moment
important puisque c'était aussi le
premier contact avec Marine Le Pen c'est
le moment où j'ai réalisé que loin des
fantasques même j'avais personnellement
véhiculé par un certain nombre
d'opposants par une petite doxam
médiatico-politique ben Marine Le Pen
est une femme humaine avec qui on avait
eu des échanges très très clairs des
dans l'intérêt général dans l'intérêt
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas elle quoi
pourquoi pas c'est vrai que ça m'a fait
forcer alors que j'étais encore très
jeune à négocier cet accord au code de
Nicolas parce que au final énormément
autour de lui aussi de refuser de
travailler avec Marine Le Pen et donc ça
a été cette première contact qui m'a
donné envie par la suite de m'engager
pour Marine Le Pen alors vous êtes
plusieurs députés RN à avoir une place
importante assez cotée aux côtés de
Marine Le Pen a être passé par Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan on vous voit ici avec
Jean-Philippe Tanguy ou Alexandre Loubet
vous avez créé ensemble même un petit
parti un micro parti comme on dit
l'avenir français
ça veut dire que c'est une bonne école
de la politique Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
moi je remercie
locale moi j'ai appris énormément à ses
côtés et c'est vrai que je suis ultra
heureux d'être avec mes compagnons de
route qui était à debout la France
aujourd'hui au côté de Marine Le Pen ce
qui est certain c'est que on n'a pas
changé on veut le rassemblement de tous
les patriotes de tous les nationaux pour
sauver le pays et éviter d'être dans
leur nenir que nous connaissons
actuellement c'est sous les couleurs
donc de l'avenir français que vous êtes
présenté au législatives avec le soutien
du rassemblement national et de Marine
Le Pen il se trouve que Jean-Michel
Blanquer a choisi de se présenter dans
la même circonscription que vous ça eut
pour conséquence de braquer un peu les
caméras sur vous vous diriez que que
cette candidature de Jean-Michel
Blanquer finalement c'était une chance
pour vous oui en quelque sorte ça m'a
obligé à
arrêter d'être le garçon timide qui
voulait être en arrière-plan qui voulait
pas répondre aux caméras c'est pour ça
que vous avez des difficultés à trouver
des images ça m'a forcé puisque de
manière pour une question d'équipe des
temps de parole je devais m'exprimer et
ça m'a permis aussi de de me faire un
petit peu un petit nom à ce moment là et
et de pouvoir aider mon arrivée à
l'Assemblée nationale va être
porte-parole et ce qui s'est passé c'est
à dire que très vite après votre
élection Marine Le Pen vous a repéré
elle vous a nommé porte-parole du groupe
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée et
où vous êtes retrouvé encore plus en
pleine lumière alors que vous dites que
vous n'aimez pas cela pourquoi vous
dites pas cela parce que vous avez l'air
plutôt à l'aise parce que je pense que
j'aime pas l'image que je renvoie c'est
de la psychologie voilà on sait où on
s'aime pas on apprend à s'aimer au fur
et à mesure aussi où on grandit
physiquement dans la manière de
s'exprimer et puis aussi parce que je
pense que dans un premier temps j'avais
un complexe de classe un sentiment de
l'imposteur quand je suis arrivé ici et
historiquement c'est-à-dire je me disais
qu'est-ce que le petit gars de la
ruralité dont les parents ont pas fait
d'études qu'est-ce qui fait dans ce
milieu en fait quand on arrive on se
rend pas légitime à votre place de la
légitimité des yeux mais en finale oui
je me sentais pas à ma place et je pense
que c'est ce qui arrive à énormément de
députés qui ne viennent pas des milieux
habituels qui ne répètent pas en fait la
vie familiale qui sont souvent d'une
famille très politisée on a l'impression
que c'est pas pour nous et c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est intéressant que les
jeunes issus d'un autre milieu qui
s'engagent en politique et moi je leur
dis c'est pas réservé seulement aux fils
de au fils à papa l'Assemblée nationale
doit représenter tous les Français on va
passer à notre quiz après présent si
vous voulez bien je vous explique
comment ça se passe c'est très simple je
vais commencer une phrase et c'est vous
qui allez devoir la compléter
on commence ce qui m'agace le plus à
l'Assemblée le bois permanent c'est à
dire le fait que chacun est là pour
faire sa petite vidéo pour faire le buzz
et pas forcément toujours pour débattre
du fond et puis aussi la deuxième chose
qui m'agace il y en a deux c'est le côté
très secteur des autres groupes c'est à
dire que moi je vois des propositions
qui viennent de gauche de droite de la
majorité je pense juste à l'intérêt des
Français est-ce que ne fait pas tous les
députés malheureusement contrairement au
RN l'avenir français alors le RN c'est
un mouvement de rassemblement ni droite
ni gauche gauche et droite nous nous
sommes de droite gaulliste vous assumez
de droite gaulliste sans hésitation et
c'est la beauté duration nationale c'est
de rassembler des personnes qui viennent
d'horizon différents enfin dans une
autre vie je rêverais de
je rêverais d'avoir du temps parce que
c'est le problématique en plus
aujourd'hui politique maintenant et on
se rend compte à quel point c'est une
denrée rare c'est d'avoir du temps pour
sa famille pour ses proches pour
souffler et pour des fois prendre un
petit une petite bouffée d'air frais
pour être encore plus efficace pour
défendre les Français et bien merci
beaucoup d'être venu dans la politique
et moi
[Musique]